- This episode of Legal Eagle
was made possible by Skillshare.
Learn to think like a lawyer for free
for two months by clicking on
the link in the description.
Usually claiming this is
a constitutional crisis
in this administration is just hyperbole,
but something was different
when the administration
attempted to include
a citizenship question
in the American census.
The Supreme Court has
already answered that query
with a big fat no, that 2020 census
cannot include the citizenship
question on the census.
And the government's lawyers
told the lawyer courts
that they were prepared to comply
with the Supreme Court's order,
until president Trump
tweeted that actually
as leader of the US government,
he might just use that question anyway.
And behold, we have
what might be considered
a constitutional crisis on our hands.
Can a president defy or
ignore Supreme Court order?
Has this ever happened before?
And are we out of the
woods when it comes to
a constitutional crisis?
That's what we're gonna talk about today
on this real law review.
(dramatic music)
Hey Legal Eagles, it's time
to think like a lawyer.
Since the day president Donald Trump
took the oath of office,
people have been predicting
a constitutional crisis.
The constitution doesn't
define anything like
a constitutional crisis,
it's basically just a term
that we come up with
when we have to suggest
lots of danger when it
comes to the interplay
between different branches
of the US government.
But a constitutional crisis
over whether one branch
of the US government would
acknowledge the full authority
of another is a kind of a
big deal in its own right,
and that's pretty much where we are today.
It appears that we may
be safe for the moment,
but it's worth doing a full retrospective
on the census controversy,
because things keep getting
weirder and we're not
out of the woods yet.
So how did we get here?
First, a primer on the American census.
The census requires
the government to count
the population of the United
States every 10 years.
Counting the population
includes all people,
whether citizens or non-citizens.
The census is mandated by the constitution
in Article 1, which
governs Congress's power.
The Constitution requires
a census every 10 years.
Congress delegates that power
to the executive branch,
but it is a constitutionally-mandated
congressional power.
The question of who to
include in the census
goes back to the founding of this country
and the infamous 3/5ths compromise.
At the time, the southern
states, which had huge
populations of slaves,
wanted to count those
when it came to
congressional representation,
while the northern states
felt that that was unfair
because all of these
slaves were not considered
US citizens, so for better or worse,
the states reached the
infamous 3/5ths compromise.
The census is used to
allocate federal funds,
draw legislative districts,
and reapportion congressional seats.
Although the census once
included a citizenship question,
the Census Bureau dropped
the question in the 1950s
because it caused an under
count of the actual population.
According to Census Bureau experts,
the citizenship question
scares people who live
in households that include non-citizens.
Census responses are supposed
to remain confidential
and cannot be given to
any other federal agencies
to assist deportations, but many people
simply don't know or
believe that their answers
will be kept confidential,
and including the question
can be particularly
intimidating to immigrants.
Some studies have shown that including
the citizenship question
reduces the actual response
rate among households with
a least one non-citizen
by as much as eight percentage points,
and that is a pretty big deal.
The ultimate goal of including
the citizenship question,
as explained by republican
strategist Thomas Hofeller,
is to allow republicans to create heavily
gerrymandered maps where
likely democratic voters
are stuffed into geographically
small urban districts.
Although Hofeller passed
away, his correspondence
indicated that he wanted
to use citizen population
instead of total population
to draw legislative districts,
which in his words, quote,
would be advantageous
to republicans and non-Hispanic whites,
and would dilute the
political power of Hispanics.
According to the New York Times,
Hofeller wrote to Trump
and other republicans
even before the president was inaugurated
urging the Trump administration to include
the census question and
obfuscate the reason
for including it, claiming
that it was necessary
to enforce the Voting Rights Act.
Once president Trump was inaugurated,
he followed Hofeller's blueprint,
and despite arguing in
court that the question
was meant to enforce
minority voting rights,
in public, Trump admitted
that that was not,
in fact, correct.
The real reason, well
president Trump stated.
- You need it for
Congress for districting.
You need it for appropriations.
Where are the funds going?
How many people are there?
Are they citizens, are they not citizens?
You need it for many reasons.
- In other words, you need it to do
precisely what Hofeller said,
to create an under count that would help
republicans and hurt democrats.
Several states sued the federal government
after the Trump administration
announced it would
use the census to ask people
if they were US citizens.
As those cases wound their
way through the federal court
system, the Trump administration didn't do
a particularly good job of coming up
with a facially neutral reason
for including the question.
And in fact, although
Hofeller died a few years ago,
his daughter discovered
documents on his hard drive
that showed the citizenship
question was designed
for the purpose of giving
white voters more power.
While it's not 100% clear,
it is entirely possible
that the Supreme Court used that evidence
to determine that the Trump
administration's reasoning
for including the question
was in fact pretextual.
So the Supreme Court said that Trump
and Labor Secretary Ross
could not put the question
on the 2020 census, and in fact,
I covered that case in the round-up
of Supreme Court cases from
this term linked below.
Now during the litigation,
the government had
repeatedly told the
courts that they needed
to print census forms
no later than June 30th.
That rationale allowed them to skip
the intermediate appeals court entirely
and go straight to the Supreme Court.
The Supreme Court's decision
happened shortly before
that deadline, so when
the Supreme Court remanded
the case back down to
the lower federal courts,
the Department of Justice
attorneys responsible
for arguing the government's position
told the courts that the
cases were basically over
and that the government
would print the census
by June 30th as scheduled,
without question.
Now normally that would be the
end of this particular story,
at least until the next
census in 10 years,
but president Trump had other ideas.
Quote, so important for our
country that the very simple
and basic are you a citizen
of the United States
question be allowed to be
asked in the 2020 census.
Department of Commerce
and Department of Justice
are working very hard on this,
even on the fourth of July.
DOJ lawyers were caught
flat-footed by this tweet,
and in fact federal
court Judge George Hazel,
who is presiding over one
of the two census questions
in the US district for Maryland,
said that he followed Trump on Twitter
and hauled all of the
lawyers, both the plaintiffs
and the DOJ defense
lawyers, into his court
for an emergency conference
with all of the attorneys.
In the court conference,
Judge Hazel said that
he follows president Trump on Twitter,
and that the tweet, quote,
directly contradicted
the position that the DOJ
had taken 48 hours earlier.
The transcript of this
particular conference
is pretty remarkable,
even for a layperson.
I would never want to
be on the receiving end
of the vitriol that Judge Hazel issued
towards the DOJ lawyers, and believe me,
contradicting something
that you have promised
to a judge is definitely not a position
that any lawyer ever wants to take.
But DOJ lawyer Joshua Gardner had to tell
the federal court judge "the
tweet this morning was the
"first I'd heard of the president's
position on this issue."
In other words, Gardner had no idea
what his boss was going to do or say
with the government's new position.
Later that same day, the
lawyers had the unenviable task
of telling judges in
all of the pending cases
that all of the stuff he had said earlier
about printing the forms on July 30th
and obeying the Supreme Court, well,
they were basically
trying to take that back.
So could president Trump
really defy an order
from the Supreme Court?
Well the framers of the
Constitution believed strongly
in checks and balances,
building a system of governance
where the three branches of government
constantly have the
ability to stop each other
from gaining too much power,
and in the famous 1803
Marbury versus Madison,
the Supreme Court
established a legal doctrine
known as judicial review, which is ability
of the court to declare
legislative or executive acts
in violation of the Constitution.
Now judicial review was
controversial at the time,
since it's not explicitly
found in the Constitution.
However, it has basically
been the law of the land
ever since 1803.
At the time, Alexander
Hamilton wrote that, quote,
the courts were designed
to be an intermediate body
between the people and
the legislature in order,
among other things, to keep
the latter within the limits
assigned to their authority.
James Madison once said
that an independent judicial
system provided, quote,
an impenetrable bulwark
against every assumption of power
in the legislative or executive.
And so as time went on, the
Supreme Court got the final say
over whether a law was
constitutional or not.
There's actually nothing
that can force the president
to follow the orders of the Supreme Court.
The court system doesn't have an army,
it really doesn't have any police officers
except for a few marshals who basically
are just there for the
protection of the judges.
Judicial review is one
of the strongest norms
in the American government,
but presidents have
ignored Supreme Court decisions before.
Let's start with the first real example
of a president defying the Supreme Court,
Andrew Jackson and the Cherokees.
Ever since the Revolutionary War,
the United States had
openly desired to take
Cherokee and Creek land in
what is now the American south,
and Georgia had claimed
over 100 million acres
of Cherokee land as its own.
The federal government
originally backed the tribes
and signed treaties
guaranteeing that they would
never have to move,
treaties that the government
would finally break when
President Andrew Jackson
came along and signed
the Indian Removal Act,
which aimed to force
Cherokees off their land.
The Cherokee government
argued that they had
the same rights as any sovereign nation
and therefore passed a law restricting
white Europeans from
residing on Cherokee land.
The ensuing court case wound
up before the Supreme Court,
which ruled for the Cherokee nation.
Chief Justice John Marshall wrote that
the Cherokee had sovereignty,
which included the same
rights of possession
as any other nation over its own land.
The court reasoned that the
tribe could exclude people
from buying its land or residing there.
President Jackson, however,
had very different ideas.
President Jackson supposedly said
"John Marshall has made his decision,
"now let him enforce it."
Georgia decided to simply ignore
the Supreme Court's order,
and President Jackson
proceeded to let Georgia
do what it wanted, and that is how
the Cherokee ended up
leaving Georgia for Oklahoma
on a journey that is known
as the Trail of Tears.
By refusing to do anything to enforce
the Supreme Court's decision,
President Jackson was
daring the court to intervene,
knowing that the court's
enforcement mechanisms
were shaky at best, and
at times in the past,
the court had ordered federal
marshals to enforce orders,
but there isn't really any
constitutional authority
allowing for this.
The US Marshalls work
for the Attorney General.
The Attorney General is part
of the executive branch,
so the Supreme Court
couldn't send in the marshals
even if they wanted to.
In a different case, one
of the biggest stains
on Abraham Lincoln's presidency
was when he suspended
the writ of habeas corpus
during the Civil War.
A writ of habeas corpus
is a legal term that means
that every person in prison has a right
to petition the courts
for his or her release.
Habeas corpus is actually
a right that is enumerated
in the Constitution, but
Lincoln suspended habeas corpus
rights early in the Civil War,
preferring to hold prisoners
without any mechanism for their release.
The Supreme Court held
that what Lincoln did
was in fact unconstitutional,
but President Lincoln ignored the order
because he was more worried
about the war itself.
And again, there was
nothing the Supreme Court
could do because its orders
are not self-executing.
This means that the court
doesn't have any ability
to enforce its own orders.
In reality, the Supreme Court
and other federal courts
have to depend on the executive branch
to enforce their orders
since the executive is responsible
for enforcing the laws,
and the vast majority of
presidents have viewed it
as their constitutional duty
to obey Supreme Court rulings,
and even enforce them.
When the Supreme Court
held that states could not
maintain an education system
that was separate but equal,
the governor of Arkansas
resisted racial integration,
but at that time,
President Dwight Eisenhower
used his authority to call on the military
to enforce the Supreme
Court's integration order.
President Eisenhower said
whenever normal agencies
prove inadequate to the
task, it becomes necessary
for the executive branch
of the federal government
to use its powers and authority
to uphold federal courts.
- The president's
responsibility is inescapable.
In accordance with that responsibility,
I have today issued an executive order
directing the use of troops
under federal authority
to aid in the execution of federal law
at Little Rock, Arkansas.
- The National Guard went to Little Rock
to help make sure that
the Little Rock Nine,
as they were known, were
allowed to go to school,
enforcing Brown versus Board of Education.
Most of the time, presidents
will sharply criticize
Supreme Court decisions,
but they will still
follow the court's orders.
This was the case in 2004,
when Supreme Court struck down
president George W. Bush's
plan to have prisoners
held in Guantanamo Bay
tried by military tribunals
rather than the court system.
Similarly in 2010, President
Obama sharply criticized
the Citizens United case, but still,
President Obama did not decline to follow
the opinion as laid out
by the Supreme Court,
nor did he issue an executive order
imposing a new campaign
finance system unilaterally.
It's common for politicians
to have an opinion
about whether cases are
wrongly decided or not,
but it is not normal in modern times
for presidents to ignore
Supreme Court orders,
which brings us to the
current administration.
Did the founders leave
us totally and completely
unable to defend ourselves
against a president
who won't obey a court order?
Well, the founders of America created
three co-equal branches of government,
and gave the legislative branch the duty
to impeach a president who commits both
quote, high crimes and misdemeanors.
Now, defining high crimes and misdemeanors
is beyond the scope of this video,
but there are plenty of
constitutional scholars
who believe that it is Congress's duty
to impeach a president who
refuses to follow the law
or refuses to follow
Supreme Court precedent.
Now president Trump tends to
tweet about a lot of things
that make him angry, and
often fails to follow through
with some of the things
that he states via Twitter,
and it's possible that census
tweets from the president
are just another example of
saying one thing and doing another.
But here, president Trump
first took to Twitter
to trash the Supreme Court's ruling,
and then said he would consider using
an executive order to add
the census question by fiat,
ignoring the Supreme Court, he said.
- We're thinking about doing
that, it's one of the ways,
we have four or five ways we could do it.
It's one of the ways that we're thinking
about doing it very seriously.
- President Trump followed
up his comments with tweets
announcing that he would
make another announcement
about the census question
during a right-wing
social media gathering at the White House.
Quote, the White House
will be hosting a very big
and very important social
media summit today.
Would I have become president
without social media?
Yes, probably, at its conclusion,
we will all go to the
beautiful rose garden
for a news conference on
the census and citizenship.
However, after days of criticism,
during the news conference,
president Trump backed down
with AG Barr stating
that the administration
would not be adding a
census question after all.
Attorney General Barr
offered his interpretation
of the Supreme Court's decision
and the legality of the
citizenship question,
said that the administration
never considered
adding that question at all.
At the end of the news conference,
Attorney General Barr accused the media
of being hysterical by
stating that Trump would use
an executive order to usurp
the Supreme Court when
the administration had never,
ever considered doing that.
- Some in the media have been suggesting
in the hysterical mode of the day
that the administration
has been planning to add
the citizenship question to the census
by executive fiat without
regard to contrary court orders
or what the Supreme Court might say.
This has been based on rank
speculation and nothing more.
As should be obvious,
there has never been,
this has never been under consideration.
- I don't really know how to square
this statement with reality.
The president said exactly
the opposite of this
and the news media was
relying on the tweets
and actual verbal statements
that the president made,
including a question and answer
from a reporter to president Trump.
The reporter asked "are you going to issue
"an executive order on the census?"
to which president Trump replied
"we're thinking about doing that.
"It's one of the ways,
we have four or five ways
"we can do it, it's one of
the ways we're thinking about
"doing it very seriously.
"We're doing well on the census."
So according to the president himself,
of course the citizenship
question was under consideration.
It's hard to criticize the news media
for being hysterical when
they're simply reporting
what president Trump himself said.
Now one of the consequences
of Barr and Trump's reversals
is that the DOJ lawyers
were thrown under the bus
in front of the federal courts.
Rather than continue litigating this case,
all of the DOJ lawyers asked
to be withdrawn from the case,
both in the Maryland case
and in the New York case,
which is basically an unprecedented move.
It really hearkens back to
the Saturday night massacre under Nixon.
The Department of
Justice would not say why
those lawyers asked to be
withdrawn from the case,
but it's safe to say that
some of them refused to
go back into court and
contradict their prior statements
to the judges, and to potentially defy
the Supreme Court's precedent.
The two federal judges who are overseeing
the various census cases were not amused
by this attempt to withdraw.
Judge Furman of the US District Court
for the southern district of New York
would not allow any of
the lawyers to withdraw
in the middle of the case, and stated that
the government's reasoning
to withdraw from the case
were patently deficient.
Judge Furman also said
that the government itself
was responsible for making the case
a time-sensitive emergency.
Quote, as this court
observed many months ago,
this case has been
litigated on the premise
based in no small part on
defendants' own insistence
that a speedy resolution
of plaintiffs' claims
is a matter of great private
and public importance.
This all goes back to the
government's insistence
that the case needed to be
wrapped up by June 30th,
and that deadline had expired.
In the end, Judge Furman
denied the motion to withdraw
for nine of the 11 lawyers.
The two who were granted
leave had apparently
quit the Department of
Justice prior that decision.
Judge Hazel in the Maryland
district federal court
followed suit by refusing to allow
the government lawyers to withdraw.
Judge Hazel, who's the one that conducted
the emergency court conference,
said that a change in counsel did not give
the government a do-over,
and that even if it added
new lawyers, the government
would still have to
answer for the statements it made before.
Quote, a change in counsel does not create
a clean slate for a party to proceed
as if prior representations
made to the court
were not in fact made.
A new DOJ team will need to
be prepared to address these
and other previous representations made by
the withdrawing attorneys
at the appropriate juncture.
For the time being, it looks
like the administration
is indeed backing down and
respecting the Supreme Court
decision, however, the
house has voted to hold
Attorney General Barr and
commerce secretary Wilbur Ross
in contempt of Congress for their refusal
to turn over key documents that relate
to the Trump administration's attempt
to add the citizenship
question to the 2020 census.
So this in fact may just be the beginning
of another potential
constitutional crisis and dispute.
Now it's unlikely that
Attorney General Barr
fooled anyone about
what the president said
or what the administration
was trying to do.
He really could have
benefited from Sabaa Tahir's
Skillshare class, Writing
Authentic Fiction,
How to Build a Believable Character.
Sabaa walks you through
her personal process
for crafting authentic
and believable characters.
It's packed with exercises, prompts,
and tried and true techniques
that teach you how to create
real and nuanced characters
that feel like they could
walk right off the page.
After taking that Skillshare class,
you might actually be
able to convince people
that your character is telling the truth.
Skillshare is an online learning community
that has over 30,000
classes on everything,
like lifestyle, design, and technology.
Legal Eagles will get two
free months of Skillshare
when you click on the link below,
plus it really helps out this channel.
The free premium membership
gives you unlimited access
to must-know topics so you
can improve your skills
and learn new things,
all free for two months.
So click on the link below
to get two free months of
Skillshare and start learning
to think like a lawyer today.
Do you agree?
Do you think the citizenship question
should be on the census?
Do you think the
administration will be able to
come up with another
justification that passes muster?
Leave your objections in the comments
and check out my other
real law reviews over here,
where I will see you in court.